And then it's all good. Uh, D have you seen the, the, uh, the, uh,
the ice cream licking challenge that people are talking about?
They should be calling it the, how long you go to jail for a challenge,
because people just go out, you shoot, you can look this up, you can just dig,
go out. And they have you heard about this? You have, Oh, okay.
I thought I was honest, some new. And they,
they go in to like a Rite aid and they grabbed the, go to the ice cream.
They grab it, open it up, lick it, and then put it back. Dude.
If I saw someone do that, I'd sweep him. I'd sweep them.
I'd sweep them. I do a one of those spins sweeps. And they'd go on there.
They fall down on their. Dude. If I see someone do that, man, sweep them.
If you see someone do that, sweep them, go over the leg.
What's the a sweep. The leg in karate kid. That's me, dude.
I'm going to bring a blonde hair dude in right aides. Look for people like that.
When we see it, I'm going to hear him say, slip the leg,
and I'm going to go for the leg, dude. I'm going to do a spin sweep.
I hope it hurts, dude, because that's you,
you can go to jail for that. That's my practice.
I mean, I know you're not a doctor, but that's my practice.
You might be a doctor maybe doing the ice cream challenge and,
and you are a doctor now that's my practice.
And I will Sue you I'll buy the ice cream, eat it to Sue you. You understand me?
Unless you have a gross mouth. Some people have grosses, mouths. Huh?
You ever talked to somebody and they're talking with their mouth and you're just
like, Whoa, what are you doing? Like, what is going on in there?
You know, like they got weird teeth or like that weird yellow,
like, or like sometimes it's like gray in their mouth. And you're just like,
you feel like you're looking at like, they're like.
Like you D you have to feel that same way. You're like, why did,
why did you show me that? You know,
that's how I feel when sometimes people talk to me and they're,
I'm looking in their mouth talking, and I'm just like,
why are you showing me this?
If someone like dad did the ice that did the ice cream challenge, dude,
Hey, meet the floor. Cause you're getting sweeped. Um,
yeah. Are you some dust?
Cause you're getting sweeped. I'm a janitor. Boom sweep. You're on your
answer. You do it. That's it's just a, yeah. The ice cream challenge.
That's so up. Or, or, or I,
or I would do this from across the way. If I saw you do that, I would go like,
I'll be, I would, I will put my fist up and I will be running towards you.
And I'd be like,
here comes the punch in the face and then boom hit you and you wouldn't.
And I would connect to
either the sweep or here comes a punch in the face,
similar to the ice cream. Oh, Oh, here's another one that he's sending me
get. Oh, Oh yeah. The gallon smashing. This is less bad, but it's real bad.
The gallon Smith. Oh good, good,
good, good. Congratulations. Wow. I just saw a guy do it, bro.
That's the dumbest thing I've ever seen in my life. It's also very,
very white to do that. This is so white gallon smashing compilation.
The first guy takes the gallon, smashing smashes,
the two gallons of milk slips and smashes. His jaw.
We don't even need to sweep this guy.
Oh. I think it broke my jaw. It, no, you know what?
I bet he's from like Austin, Texas and became Irish.
That's how hard he hit his head. He's like, Oh,
y'all want to do the gown set. Smashing can't blame Yondu down.
Smashing what's that boy. Well that's when you take the yo them, uh,
tomorrow take gallon milk. You just smash it on the ground.
The guy says one gallon we're going to do to, I guess is, well, all right,
sounds dangerous. But let's do it.
And they go and they do it and they grabbed the two gals and guys remember
record this and does it swung? Boom hit so hard. He's gone. Oh,
brought me Joel, immediate Cockney.
The. Hard to watch. That's really, really,
really hard to watch.
And I've seen SciQuest
joust jousting, dude. You know, it's like with the gallon,
the gallon smashing cup competition.
And then they get in the one time. My brother and I, you know, those, we were,
we were dumb, but we were really young. Uh, you know, those, uh, um,
what do you call them? Uh, uh, coupons, things that you would,
they will be in the aisle and you could just take one and then another one will
pop out my brother and I would collect them.
We would run around the whole stores and open it and it would go, boom.
And then another one where we went around the whole store and then this guy had
his suit. That was, we were in New Jersey, but he was so New Jersey.
He was like, all right guys, all right, fellas, you got to give them to me.
You got to stop doing that. And I was like, here you go. And I felt so bad.
I went back to my mom and was like, mom, we got into a trouble.
He's great. Kids are. You know what? These kids are. They're all rich.
It's like, they got too much, their family has too much money.
It's so not it here's the number one thing.
It's so not worth it. You know?
Like what's the thing. Oh, they gotta clean it up. Okay.
Someone saw you. Uh it's.
So you're basically the guy at the Halloween party that dressed up in the
outfit. That's like, like, uh, you're like,
you're the person who put on a slip and wrote Freud on it. And you're like,
I don't know, like I'm a Freudian slip and this is, and the guy goes, Oh yeah,
that's you, you're the fun guy at the Halloween party. You.
But also you're making, you're putting people out.
Look what I am. Um, you're,
you're dressed as a chicken and you got a cord connected to you to a blue circle
and you're like, look, I'm chicken cord on blue. Oh, cool, man.
Oh, you made a play on words, Halloween costume dude. You're the first to go
look at these gallon smashing. Oh. And then he's hammered it up, falling down,
like, like his Buster Keaton.
So not funny. It's what not funny people do too.
Cause they don't have personalities. So they just
excuse they're slipping. It's not even worth recording, dude.
It's so stupid. All good.
All good.
If I saw someone do that,
I'd take the gallon and throw another gallon on them or just dump it out on him
one time. Oh dude, one time, you know how
you know how, Oh dude, this is how I was as a kid.
One time somebody poured something on my head as like a joke.
And I was a kid.
I was a kindergarten kid or whatever it was or maybe I was in first or second
grade, bro. This is the kind of kid I was. Okay. So,
you know,
on like shows when somebody pours a glass on somebody's
head,
they pour a little bit on it and it's real quick and the person just goes like
this and they just sit there. When in real life,
of course you would go like, yo, what the? and grab their hand.
And their cup would go flying and. And we all awkward.
But in movies and TV shows, especially in the eighties,
which was when I was a kid,
somebody would pour some on your head and the person would just go like this.
And if they had long hair, they'd go. Right. All right.
So somebody did that to me. I don't remember who it was. I think it was Sumatra.
She was like this little girl who in, in my, in my first grade class too,
that one time we were doing answers in the class room and she was like,
what's another one class. And I was like, I think this is an answer.
And so macho her hand and said my answer. And I go, that was my answer.
And she said, well, you didn't say it. You should have said it.
Then I stole it from you. And I was like, wow,
that's a live lesson from Sumatra who knew, right. I don't what she's doing now.
She's 40. That's crazy. So anyway, um,
somebody did, I think it was a mantra.
She poured something on my head behind me and it was like a big,
it wasn't just was like a lot. And I did the thing that they do in movies.
And I go and I waited and she,
this kept pouring on the and I waited an extra second. I was like,
what are you doing, dude? And she was like, well, why aren't you moving?
And I was like to be like the movies.
You're just supposed to pour a little bit. And then I let me do my thing.
But life isn't like the movies, you know? And that's when I realized that
when I was eight and so much a, some like a whole power eight on me.
Um, anyway, how many minutes.